you walk out of here with a bunch of
Emmys and how good does it feel it feels
nice because we can hurt people if they
come and try and take uppers there's
more than that I know but I always think
about that like I hold a whole like
moment of like if the home invasion
happened like I can put it near the bed
and then I can grab something and I
don't know but I think near my bed in
case of home invasion home invasion
because this under your mattress or for
a home invasion
how will you guys celebrate tonight
where's the party naughty before their
war show I ain't like part of a bar and
then the bar got lost and I'm still
hungry here's the most important
question that everyone is asking people
are asking this online people are asking
it everywhere season two when the hell
does it start I know but you didn't
answer me
I can't we know but Amazon for some
strange reason is not letting us say it
will be this year it will be it will be
before the end of the year sometime at
the end before the end of the year there
will be more we would love to tell you
we think that they don't have faith that
we will make our editing dates we will
we will make it so you aren't we are
gonna make it all so what does this say
about the way that people embrace this
character who kind of went against the
brain at a time when women should just
be wearing pretty makeup you know
getting up in the morning and being made
up for their husband right but instead
he or she is out on her own kind of
making her own way what does it say what
does it say that women are ready for
more stories about women that look like
the women that look and and are like the
women that we know and love missus woman
who's unapologetically confident and
ambitious and can do it all in heels
she's all of those things wrapped into
one and I think that's that's inspiring
to people I also think that midge is a
joyous character yes she even in times
where her life is crumbling you know we
make a point to not let her crumble
because she just finds everything a
challenge and there's sort of joy and
plowing hair
and it's one of the things I love most
about this character and one of the
things that that Rachel just brings in
just barrels and barrels is that that
magnetic sort of joy as she crashes
through and into things by the way does
this will usually Rachel will you see
will you see mister Bezos tonight and
will you ask him to up the budget now I
mean you guys are clearly the darling of
Amazon well you know weirdly because we
had an agreement like if I if I will
already spoke and didn't say anything
four-letter word he was gonna make those
speech and one of the things I was
thinking that we should have said it's
like you know just remember this because
the season 3 budget is going to be
coming across your desk you're sending
them that budget across I think I think
I think weirdly I think they're already
anticipating that but there have been
very good sports so far mmm raises for
everybody
Amazon can deliver stuff with drones now
they can damn sure give you more money
buy costumes yes congratulations
congratulations on tonight and I mean go
have a party we all go eat please go
okay take all these Emmys you can't you
can't sell it right if you put it on
Amazon or Ebay they'll come get you
[Music]
[Applause]